hi my name is Yu Feng Kuo and today
we're going to explore how Google clouds
data Lake solution allows enterprises to
securely ingest store process and
analyze any volume or type of data for
example a financial services company
might be getting an influx of loan
applications it's important to
accelerate the time to process and
approve the loans using machine learning
in order to get the money to the right
businesses and people faster let's walk
through how a data engineer and data
scientist can work together on the
solution using cloud storage and data
proc Data proc is a fully managed
service allowing enterprises to run
Apache spark and Apache Hadoop clusters
with 30-plus open source components in a
simple secure and cost-efficient way in
the first step of the pipeline the data
engineer will run spark jobs on data
product to convert the loan data from
CSV tables into hive tables the metadata
for the hive tables will be saved in a
new fully managed data pragmatist or
service this allows for easy discovery
and governance of your data you can now
easily create a data proc meta store
service from the data proc UI and start
using it across clusters by sharing the
service endpoint in spark it requires
just three additional lines of code to
connect to data product meta store and
enable hive table support to run the
spark job we now support running data
proc on google kubernetes engine it's
simple to set up by just including one
additional line of code to create a data
proc on gke cluster spark jobs will now
run on kubernetes instead of yarn this
reduces code dependencies and allows you
to better utilize idle cloud or
on-premise or PSA's the data engineer
can then run the spark job on the google
kubernetes engine cluster to convert the
CSV data to high of tables and data
scientists can now begin their analysis
of the loan data in the hive table by
connecting to the shared data product
Metis or service
to create the machine learning features
and model will use jupiter notebooks a
popular data science tool we've made it
easy to use jupiter notebooks and apache
spark together with data proc hub nvidia
gpus can be added to the data processor
along with installing nvidia rapids
which includes extra boost to be used in
jupiter notebooks to create that model
and using GPUs instead of CPUs can
improve training time by over 40 X let's
see how you can use these features start
from the data product notebooks UI where
you can now create a data product hub
instance which makes it easier to use
and manage to paterno books for large
teams admins can manage and control what
cluster configurations can be used by
users allowing for improved resource and
cost management you can then use a PI
SPARC notebook to create your extra
boost model first read the data using
GPUs next train a classification model
to predict loan approvals also using
GPUs then evaluate the model with one
being accepted and zero pain tonight the
model can then be saved to Google Cloud
storage and is easily loaded to be used
again in other SPARC jobs the model is
now ready to be used in production to do
batch loan approvals on new data landing
and hive tables in this demo we showed
how a financial service company can
create a model to accelerate loan
processing time using spark on data
product running on kubernetes Jupiter
notebooks Nvidia rapids and GPUs all
while storing the hive metadata in data
product meta store head on over to these
links to learn more and get started with
building your data Lake on Google Cloud
today
[Music]